the core of my campaign is the people  it's about the people and understanding  that as with any one of us we all have  lives that are complex so on the issue  of climate change every parent wants to  know that their child can drink clean  water and breathe clean air and that  same parent wants to know that they're  able to bring home enough money with one  job to pay their bills and pay their  rent and put food on the table instead  of having to work two and three jobs  every person wants to know that there  will be a criminal justice system that  is fair to all people regardless of  their race every person wants that a  mother and father should not have to sit  down with their teenage son and have the  talk and tell that child about how they  may be stopped or arrested or in some  way profiled and potentially shot  because of their race